اذا من حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث افاد
حاكم مقاطعه خرسون الاوكراني بسداد القصف
الروسي على المقاطعه الجنوبيه خلال ساعات
الماضيه واضاف ان الروسي شنوا اكثر من 70
هجوما على عموم اراضي المقاطعه واطلقوا
اكثر من ثلاثمائه قذيفه مدفعيه على
المناطق المدنيه ومواقع البنيه التحتيه في
سياق ذاتها افاد السلطات مقاطعه
خدمات الماء والكهرباء والاتصال عن العديد
من المناطق الساحليه في المقاطعه بسبب
تكثيف القصف الروسي عليها واشارت الى ان
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه اسقطت خلال اليوم
الماضي عددا من المسيرات الروسيه التي
كانت تستهدف المدينه
اكد الجيش الاوكراني صدق قواته اكثر من
اربعين هجوما روسيا خلال ساعات الماضيه
باتجاه باخموت ومارينكا شرقي البلاد واضاف
الجيش الاوكراني ان العمليات الهجوميه
الروسيه تتواصل ايضا باتجاهات شرقا مشددا
على ان بؤره الاعمال الهجوميه تتصاعد في
باقمت رغم ان الروسه تراجعوا على اكثر من
محور في المدينه وفق تعبير
اعلنت السلطات المواليه لروسيا في دونتسك
اصابه مدني بجروح في قصف اوكراني طال خمسه
عشره منطقه سكنيه خلال اليوم الماضي
وافادت السلطات ان القوات الاوكرانيه
استهدفت سكان المنطقه بنحو 300 قذيفه من
اعييره مختلفه ما الحق اضرارا ماديه
بثمانيه
واخر تابع للبنيه التحتيه المدنيه
للوقوف على الاوضاع الميدانيه انضم الينا
من ميكولايف مراسل جزيره تامر الصومالي
وميموسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا بكما ابدا
معك تامر صمادي تضعنا في صوره التطورات
الميدانيه
عبد السلام ابدا من اخر المعلومات التي
اوردتها المخابرات الاوكرانيه قبل قليل
فيما يتعلق بشبه جزيره القرم المخابرات
الاوكرانيه تدعو وتجدد دعوتها لعائلات
العسكريين الروس
والى الابتعاد والى مغادره شبه جزيره
القرم وتقول بان هنالك حركه نزوح من شبه
الجزيره باتجاه موسكو وتقول بان الجسر
الرابط بين شبه الجزيره وبين روسيا يشهد
اكتضاضا في حركه المرور وقالت بان الوقت
لازال مثاليا لمغادره شبه الجزيره وهي
تقول بان الاولويه الان والهدف الان
يتمثل في اتخاذ التدابير اللازمه لمواجهه
القوات الروسيه هناك وتقول بان التدابير
التي اخذتها خلال اليومين الماضيين تؤكد
ذلك في اشاره الى الانفجارات التي شهدتها
سلفا ستوبل يوم امس واول من امس وتقول بان
شبه الجزيره سوف تظل يعني خنجرا كما وصفته
في خاسره اوكرانيا ما لم تتوقف الاعمال
العدائيه الروسيه من هناك وقالت بانها
بالفعل تسعى وتهدف الى وقف تلك الاعمال
التي تصفها بالعدائيه لروسيا كانت هنالك
ايضا خلال دقائق الاخيره تصريحات ادلى بها
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني لوكاله انتر فاكس
الاوكرانيه قال فيها بان الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد المرتقب يشكل اولويه بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا وقال بان الدول الحليفه
والشريكه الداعمه لاوكرانيا تريد ان تشاهد
انتصارات على الارض من اجل تبرير ارسال
مزيد من المساعدات وقال بان الاولويه
الاوكرانيه تتمثل في هذه الاثناء بان هذا
الهجوم المرتقب والمزمع في هذه الاثناء
وفقا لي هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه وفقا
لقياده ايضا
الجنوب الاوكرانيه يتواصل القصف المدفعي
والصاروخي المكثف من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه بالقرب من هنا في مقاطعه
خيرسون على طول الضفه الشرقيه التي تتواجد
فيها القوات الروسيه الحديث اوكرانيا عن
تطهير كما تصفه مستمر لمواقع تواجد القوات
الروسيه هناك وفي المقابل يستمر القصف
الروسي المكثف هنا على ميكولايف لاسيما
المناطق الساحليه الحديث عن انقطاع وفقا
للسلطات المحليه في التيار الكهربائي في
الماء في الاتصالات لاسيما في مناطق
اوتشاكو فوكستراف ايضا القصف يتواصل على
خرسون القريبه والمغلقه نحاول منذ ايام في
الحقيقه عبد السلام الوصول الى عفوا الى
اخير سون دونا جدوى هنالك يعني تعامل حازم
من قبل السلطات والحديث عن اكثر من 70
هجوما روسيا على المدينه خلال الساعات
الماضيه ونهايه القتال يتواصل على الارض
في باخموت افديف كمارينكا تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انها تصد هجوم متواصل للقوات
الروسيه هناك